position right so this is a bad title
right because uh um it should say
something like this which was the
original title but from uh uh for most
of uh the language models that we work
with in uh uh deep learning these days
we uh we throw out the interesting Parts
uh of language um okay so I'm going to
start off with a couple of uh
statistical facts about language I often
get up and give these talks and I say oh
there are all these things we know about
language that linguists tell us and that
I show trees and like the machine
learning people kind of go to sleep um
so today I'm going to talk about
statistical facts things that you can go
and you can look at a lot of data and
just can't really argue with this so
this is zi's law this has been known
since the 30s uh at least uh that um
basically rare word there's sort of
basically a power law distribution of
frequencies in all natural languages and
uh another way of saying this is rare
types are extremely common and so uh
when you you unify your Corpus and throw
away sort of rare words and replace them
with this meaningless symbol uh you're
throwing away a lot of the distribution
and that's not that's probably not a
good
idea um it depends people have different
her istics uh you know uh I would say as
we've gone to deep learning more and
more uh people tend to be more
aggressive it used to be you'd throw out
Singletons now you throw out things that
occur less than you know five times even
in a million word Corpus or something
like
that um so another uh way of stating
this is sometimes called heaps law uh
this is from the information retrieval
Community uh and it basically shows that
in any Corpus as you add more and more
documents to it you're going to see more
and more unique uh types and both of
these are sort of their nice uh uh
simple uh curves that characterize these
things um and so the last one I'm going
to take away from that is uh you cannot
model language and close the vocabulary
um you can model something languish but
uh probably uh you're you're also
missing this these These are really
robust important aspects uh of language
so uh a bunch of work that my group has
done uh over the last few years has um
said well can we uh you know without
sort of going and solving all of AI can
we do something better with language
than throwing out sort of the
interesting Parts uh of the distribution
um so I'm going to talk about two parts
of this work um so the first is uh
Building represent
of words compositionally so we're going
to find smaller bits of words hint
characters uh and morphes uh and then
we'll talk about uh dealing with uh some
of uh some more uh specific statistical
problems uh with a word reuse model uh
to get a better uh language model so
what does that to do with the unknown um
so uh the idea is we're going to find
smaller pieces there are only 26 letters
in English uh that's in English
orthography but in spoken English there
are a fixed set of phones and phon names
that are used to encode the words uh and
so that actually is closed uh so the
idea is we're going to represent these
big complex words as a function of uh uh
these little uh pieces that are closed
um which is you know how we how we
usually do these things but you should
say that's crazy because words you know
how can you know what just looking at a
new word you can't tell what it means
uh linguists even observe this uh this
is sometimes for pointing out the
obvious this is one of the reasons
linguists sometimes have a bad
reputation um so uh Cur called this
phenomenon of basically uh there being
no relationship between the way word
looks and what it means arbitrariness so
you can see this if you have the word
car you subtract a c and add a b you get
bar and it means you know something else
if you do the same thing starting with
cat that transformation you you know is
completely different so that whole
parallelogram uh analogy that we heard
about earlier in this week that
certainly uh isn't uh you're not going
to find analogies uh or at least linear
analogies here um another way we see
arbitrariness is if we look across
languages so we take a concept like car
which is historically relatively recent
we might think it was invented once and
everybody got the same word but we look
at a bunch of different languages and we
fin they all picked a completely
different word uh for this so uh you
know even when there would be a
historical reason to have some kind of
uh relation between these words we don't
see it um at the other end of the
spectrum we've got compositionality
though um and so this is basically the
idea that you can look at uh the meaning
of an expression as a uh a composition
of the meanings of component parts uh
and then the rules that were used to put
them together and this is usually
ascribed to fra but I was recently
reading that FR actually um didn't
really uh didn't really invent this it
goes back to Plato um and fraa wors
didn't even talk about it um so uh just
one of those sort of historical folk uh
Traditions so this idea is really simple
so you've got something like the
sentence John dances it's got some kind
of semantics uh like written below we
make a transformation of John to Mary uh
and we have this uh and now if we take a
similar sentence where John sing uh do
the same transformation we see that
there's a uh a similar transparent
change uh in the semantics um and so you
know really what we've got in language
learning then uh is you know it seems
like up at the lexical level we've got
arbitrariness and we've got down at the
you sort of propositional level uh we've
got compositionality that's been that
was C Sur story and that's been kind of
what we uh all start with um and of
course you know that has these have two
uh very different uh learning aspects
right I mean here all you've got you can
just memorize you can't do anything if
there's no relationship you've just got
to learn memorize it uh and otherwise we
can generalize in some interesting way
um of course I wouldn't be here uh if
things weren't quite uh if things were
that uh sort of simple uh we have some
challenges here so first we have idioms
I'm not going to say much about idioms
because these are at the propositional
level I'm talking more at the word level
uh this talk uh but basically here uh
we'll change this predicate and we no
longer get the uh nice transformation uh
that we got um uh prior to this so uh
John kick the bucket means something uh
particular so that meaning H in some
sense it's
arbitrary um on the other hand we've got
morphology uh so in English we don't
typically think that we have a lot of
word formation processes that go on that
we could be modeling uh but in fact we
do so if you go on social media you know
I'd argue this is a kind of morphology
like you know I don't think people over
in the Linguistics Department would
necessarily call it that but uh why not
um but then we've got more classical
kinds of morphology where we add an S to
the end of a word uh that says oh this
thing is plural um and if we do that to
sort of any word uh we get the same uh
pattern of uh of meanings um and we know
that uh for example this is a very
productive process you can teach a kid a
new word uh and it will uh be able to
generalize uh and produce the right form
when uh context calls for it to produce
something that would have a plural
semantics um so you know there's a
little bit of compositionality we might
be able to exploit here um so when
learning uh linguistic representation uh
basically these are these two kind of
extremes that a learner has to contend
with um and I'd say although we do see
more arbitrariness at the level of IND
individual words uh we really do see
kind of this uh gradation between we see
arbitrariness at the level of sentences
and we see compositionality at the level
of words and so really we need Learners
that uh can can be flexible and sort of
move between these two extremes easily
um and uh in general what we've been
doing in this work is taking lstms which
are nominally a model which read in
multiple things and then put them
together in some way and we which we
usually have claimed are good for
generalization uh and we're going to use
them to uh also force them to memorize
basically and uh the interesting thing
of course is that if you look at where
uh deep learning models often fail it's
because they tend to memorize a little
bit too much it's a little bit hard for
them to uh um to make the necessary
abstractions that they that they ought
to be um very brief I just want to
mention that mean at The Lex level
meeting so I'll I'll talk about the I'll
talk about the uh the the one of the
uses here in just one second but
basically we're going to be reading
characters uh and then building word
representations out of those um I'm also
just going to mention you know uh we've
had a we've never been really great
about working on languages other than
English in uh uh in NLP uh but uh it's
sort of gotten particularly bad maybe
now that we think we might be able to do
some really interesting uh uh NLP uh
with deep learning uh but there's really
languages work very differently uh even
just looking at the lexical level you
can talk about the complexity uh of
different languages and they uh with the
complexity of the words they use and uh
we can have a typology uh of languages
and so words in languages like English
or Mandarin Chinese are are pretty
Atomic and they refer to sing single
Concepts um but as we go to the sort of
down we get increasingly complex words
and so you know in a glutena of language
like Turkish you might have a single
word form uh that means something like
they caused it not to meow or something
like that uh and then there are these uh
even more uh complex languages um called
polysynthetic languages which can kind
of contain full propositions and single
words but there aren't very many of
those that's a single word that could be
something like this would be a single
word and like inititate apparently I
don't speak the thing is not very there
are very few speakers of these languages
left they're fairly rare and so there's
some controversy it's not like German
where together it it is it's uh so there
are pieces that fit together but they
behave differently than words in a
sentence do there are uh there
Diagnostics um some of which are
controversial but it's kind of it's kind
of like German um okay so here's here's
going to be uh the model that we're
going to start with so the St the
simplest memorization model is what we
use all the time I would argue in uh
modeling language with uh uh in deep
learning so we take a word and we
project it into uh a one hot Vector
every Dimension corresponds to uh you
know one position uh in the vocabulary
um of course this is fixed um fix sized
embedding and then we project this down
uh into some low dimensional space and
we learn this projection and so this
projection Matrix that we left multiply
by uh is going to or right multiply I
guess since this is a row Vector um is
going to have uh a vector for every word
uh in this uh um uh in the language and
so each of those parameters are going to
be independent related words are just
going to be as you know independ
independently parameterized as words
that are very similar so cat and cats
will be have each have their own
parameters just like cat and generalize
will um so uh on the other side we're
going to work with this generalization
model which uh when we actually proposed
this we didn't really think this was
sensible um and so I'm still sort of
surprised when it works we're going to
view uh car as a sequence
C uh and we will embed this uh each of
those characters and we're going to
assume there's a a fixed number of these
which is a more reasonable assumption uh
and then we'll read this with a
bidirectional lstm I wasn't here on
Monday for Chris's talk but apparently
he informed you all the bidirectional
lstms are what you need for basically
every problem in NLP these days this is
yet another example uh we'll combine
these uh to get a vector representation
uh in exactly the same space so the
difference is um you can think about
this as having this big learned Matrix
living on this Arrow um and uh this is
parameterizing this Matrix using this uh
rnm the difference is Um this can take
any sequence in um and so we we get uh
um sort of uh an effectively infinite
Matrix
there um okay so and we're going to in
both of these cases we're going to train
these parameters or the parameters that
of this Matrix or the parameters that
live in inside this bidirectional RNN uh
using back back propagation from some
task that's consuming uh these word
vectors so these could be things like
modeling sequences of words they could
be things like translation or text
classification um I am going to uh talk
about uh dependency parsing uh I had a
postto who was really into this uh Noah
talked about this on Wednesday so you
guys are all experts and so the ideas
will be given sentences like this and
we'll predict this uh uh rooted uh tree
uh here and the way we're going to do
this is we're just we've got uh two
parsers and we are going to uh compare
two different ways of representing the
inputs one is just going to be these
Word Lookup tables uh and the other is
going to be using these character uh
bidirectional lstms what's the desired
output uh the desired output so we are
uh uh building this tree up with a
sequence of action
using actually a shift reduced parser to
build that so this is uh very similar to
the model that uh that Noah talked about
on Wednesday we're going to uh either
alternate between uh um between shifting
words off of the sentence and into a
into a stack or combining elements on
the stack to build little treelets and
this process will terminate when there's
only one thing left on the stack uh and
that's a tree and when we combine two
things we you know put a link between uh
between the two of them and the links
are saying who did the ducking and who
did the yeah exactly that's saying I am
roughly it points to its arguments so
you can think about these words so
predicates or verbs have uh the subject
and object as their uh arguments uh duck
uh or nouns have uh their modifiers to
things like adjectives and possessive
pronouns and things like that um there
this dependency why See Saw going to
duck and not to her uh so this is a
linguistic convention uh there are some
reasons that linguists have uh argued
that in most cases the main verb of the
sentence is the root of the sentence uh
the directedness is just uh it makes
this work out as a tree uh so with a
single root um so things point at their
arguments rather than the other way
around um if it's more convenient
conceptually to think the other way
around you can reverse the arrows but
this gives you a tree I mean her is the
is the object of C not um no oh in this
yeah that's no there's Ambi ambiguity
here that's why I picked the sentence so
in one one reading of the senten say she
has a duck and in the other case I saw
her ducking under the and in that case
you saw her um so yeah oh you you got
the other reading okay you're I think
you're the first person to ever actually
get the confusion uh and that was why I
picked this example um everybody else
understood okay yeah no this is yeah
your mind works differently that's great
um right so yeah that's the that's the
confusion um so these are somewhere
between kind of a semantic and a
syntactic uh analysis uh and uh it's a
little more oriented to some syntactic
conventions um all right so basically
the idea is we're just going to replace
the first level of this network that's
driving this parser the representations
we'll either have uh lookups that come
from a table where every word gets its
own set of parameters
or we're going to have the single
Network and we're going to be Computing
this Vector representation uh as a
function of the sequence of characters
representation two cases are the same
Dimension same same Dimension exactly
yeah um and yeah we picked something
sort of reasonable for the internal
architecture yeah I just have a question
so even before you use these
representations in anything did you
actually look at if you make small
orthographic
changes where where you get a big
semantic difference in the word but it's
a small I guess like for example if you
change a b to a c some words might
change completely in meaning but other
words might not and is the case that the
second model does a better job
understanding the context in which the
small orographic change occurs in so I
will I do have some examples uh later in
the talk showing getting at this we have
we have done a fair amount of analysis
of what these things are learning um
there's also a little bit of controversy
about the relationship between uh uh
like the form of words and the
uh semantics there is uh recently or
this claim periodically comes up that
Cur was sort of overly pessimistic and
actually languages abound in these
things where there are relationships
between sound and meaning sometimes
they'll call these things like um uh uh
what graphos semantic question I'm
trying to ask is if you make a one
character change to the string do you
find that in certain words that one
character change makes a drastic
difference of representation while as in
other words that same one character
change makes practically no difference
uh we okay right we we haven't we
haven't looked at done precisely that
test but I think the evidence will show
later suggests that that is happening I
mean that's what these nonlinear models
give you in in the potential of learning
yeah yeah that's certainly um yeah
thanks great question um okay so we'll
we'll look um uh at yeah explain that
slight just this architecture of your I
don't understand this to
layer oh the two- layer thing yes uh
sorry um the idea is um you can read a
sequence from left to right or you can
read it from right to left and uh um
it's often the case that uh um that
reading it in both directions and
combining the representations uh makes
the learning problem a little bit easier
so uh in particular for this task it
actually seems a little bit sensible so
in a lot of the languages we're going to
look at the kind of syntactically
interesting parts of the words tend to
be suffixes or they tend to be prefixes
and so you're going to have gradients
impinging on that position in the word
uh a little bit more directly than if
you were uh always had to get to the
prefix by traversing the entire word um
it wouldn't in principle it doesn't
matter uh this is just a sort of
conventional way of uh if you want a
single encoding of a sequence you can
read it from left to right or from right
to left uh and it's a little bit easier
to uh do the combination yeah
um just like a slightly technical
question have you ever tried um doing
embeddings of characters directly and
then doing an lstm on top and has that
helped or do you just go from one hot
encoding to LST oh sorry there are these
are embedded in some low dimensional
space yeah and that dimensional like is
it a different dimensionality than you
would choose for Words generally oh yeah
yeah it's it's it's a lot smaller you
just don't need that many contrasts yeah
yeah um yeah we didn't try ever scaling
every really but it seemed to plau
fairly
quickly um yeah great question please
yeah ISP by the way humans read no this
isn't this is yeah okay oh oh yeah
question I see I see so normally when
you're reading a book and there's a word
you don't know you go through the
dictionary or if it's a Kindle you just
hover on it and pops up the definition
and then that definition gives you some
sort of representation and it seems like
the UN problem could perhaps done by
having a very
nice sys espe that you know
come you C on that word and it's most
dictionaries are pretty complete I mean
dictionaries have some dictionaries have
500,000 words and it's very rare to find
words outside of some dictionary I was
gonna say wait till you work on Twitter
we actually started doing this because
my student was going to translate social
media content and uh we were sick of
trying to normalize the content before
we translated it dictionary there a lot
of online dictionaries that there there
we found 5,000 different ways of
spelling the word wood as in the you
know modal verb and so yeah I think even
Urban Dictionary has its limits um so uh
yeah that's a that's a great question uh
and I will come back to that because
obviously this is not going to give you
if you there honest if I say the you
know the word gorp or something like
that and have a particular idea in mind
you have no idea what I'm talking about
really um and there's and a dictionary
could potentially tell you that um yes
in general you need models that know
what they know and know what they don't
know and uh they either and when they
see a word they don't know they might
guess some properties about it so in
syntax if you know you know if this
looks like a noun or it's in the
position where a verb is going to be you
can probably solve this task if you're
trying to do something like translation
well you're really out of luck if you
don't know it so it depends a lot on the
task um and uh in general yeah you have
to go and find out the meaning and
looking at a dictionary which provides
very rich informative context about the
meaning of a word is one thing but
another thing to do is go out to the web
and find you know a thousand instances
where this word was used and try and
infer its meaning by reading all of
those Follow by contell Checkers might
be yeah let's I I want to go on
otherwise we're we're not going to get
far but these are great questions um
okay so the the first thing to notice is
that in English uh we actually didn't
find that this model got any worse we
thought it would it's a silly model in a
lot of ways um and uh so this really
shows that lstms are able to learn these
uh uh these very uh sort of arbitrary
relationships between the forms of words
uh and their meanings um or it just
shows that uh you don't really need to
know very much about the meanings of
words to do parsing yeah what is the
number representing oh sorry yeah these
are uh this is what's called uh labeled
attachment accuracy which is basically
when you build that tree the number of
words who have picked out the right
parent so we're saying we got 91.2% or
91.5% uh correct so basically these are
exactly the same so in this case the the
CH lstm could be remembering the things
that you've already seen and then add to
it absolutely infected and that's what
we would want it to really be able to do
um the question is we want to smooth the
long tail in kind of a sensible way and
see if it can can learn to make
generalizations about these rarer forms
as well um but yes in fact it certainly
is and you could think of creating some
really interesting adversarial examples
with models like this so we should we
should talk um um okay so in English
things are about the same um but what
about languages like this so these you
know a glutena of languages I kind of
alluded to where you can have whole
whole kind of Clauses uh in your uh in
your word I mean these are actual words
apparent like nobody's ever said those
aren't words uh to me when I've given
this talk um if we look at the
performance on those languages uh and
these are just sort of conventions that
linguists label these languages as being
of this type we see much bigger
improvements uh when we go to the
Character level model um what
performance is we talking about here I
don't understand the the numbers what do
these numbers mean oh that that was the
question just a second ago that's the
proportion of when you predict the
parent attachment for every word in the
sentence What proportion of the word
words were labeled uh as having the
right head yeah your so I'm guessing
your word representations are the same
dimensionality than whatever classif on
top also yes yeah yeah yeah every the
architecture is completely the same from
this point above
yeah and for those of you who are here
on Wednesday it's exactly the
architecture that no Smith was talking
about this was series of papers we had
done together um okay there's a sort of
level of morphological complexity now
you see why I bothered to show that uh
uh that plot uh between a glutena and
sort of simple English and uh sometimes
called uh fusional and we see that the
performance improvements are still there
but they're a little bit smaller um and
then we to round it out we also
compareed with h Chinese which is
actually probably even uh more extreme
than English in terms of having uh
little uh morphology on its words and we
also found that it uh that it works
about the same um as uh as the word
based models um so basically the story
that we we see here is that for syntax
parsing we're able to we're able to do
really well just looking at sequences of
characters and letting the lstm learn
these kind of ideosyncratic uh
differences using its uh internal
Dynamics basically we're approximating
that that embedding Matrix with an lstm
uh another way of looking at this is uh
based on how uh many out of vocabulary
words so basically how many unks would
we see in our test Set uh
uh and how much should we improve so
each of these points uh is a uh uh is a
language um obviously this is n is
something really small don't take that
line too seriously but there's
definitely a trend that as we increase
the test set at a vocabulary rate uh we
see uh more improvements um so uh that
kind of makes a certain amount of sense
um okay so what's being learned by this
model um so it's maybe questionable
whether we're actually learning much
Beyond syntactic classes so if you see a
word ending in ly you know it's an
adverb adverbs attached to verbs we'll
learn that from the training data pretty
quickly we don't really need to care
anything else about just what's the
closest adverb and what's the uh and
what's the verb and things like that um
so you know are we really learning
language so uh we're now going to look
at a more basic task language modeling
this is just the problem of density
estimation on sentences we want to
predict sequences uh of words uh this
has a been a very successful uh very
successfully solved problem in uh with
deep learning uh we're basing this on we
have lstms and at every time step we are
using that hidden current hidden
representation uh to as features to
define a uh probability distribution
over uh the output words um and in this
first uh task that I'm going to talk
about we're going to just change the way
we represent the inputs so they're
actually still going to be unks that we
are uh doing uh that we're generating uh
up top we'll fix that problem in a
second um and again we're going to see a
really similar story which is that uh
with English we basically get the same
results uh with a glutena of languages
we see uh substantial facilitation uh
and then uh the fusional languages uh
are are somewhere uh in between um
another thing that's worth noting here
uh and I think this is really
interesting to keep in mind uh the
number of parameters is an order of
magnitude or more less uh in these
things uh in these uh lstm based models
um and we should be concerned I think
about the wastefulness of our embedding
matrices in terms of our parameter
budgets uh most of in most of the models
we build everything is uh living in
these unstructured matrices and um I'm
not going to I will conclude this
section in a second by saying I don't
think lstms are it but we need to do
something there's a lot of redundancy at
that level and we should be thinking
about uh more compressed representations
so um here's another way we can ask what
these langu what this language model is
learning so a uh you know fun thing to
do along the lines of you know
parallelogram uh analogy analogical
reasoning with word vectors is to just
take a word and say what does the model
think the most similar words are and so
this gives you some insight into kind of
what it thinks is important for modeling
language and often you find things that
have similar syntactic or similar
semantic properties close by in Vector
space um and so what we're going to do
here is we're going to uh query uh the
mod we're going to build and a betting
for a query word and then for all of the
words in some fixed vocabulary we just
use the ones that were present in the
training Set uh and then we're going to
say what are the uh five nearest
neighbors and we see you know some
reasonable stuff um you know increased
we do get these other verbs but there is
some morphological similarity here uh so
maybe it's just picking up on you know
this Ed thing um I think the the John
query is a little bit more interesting
those are all names of English kings uh
so we're kind of making some uh real
semantic generalizations that aren't
quite so obviously formal kind of like
word embeddings predicting well word
this is a left to right language
modeling task this isn't a sort of
usually with word embeddings you do this
kind of pseudo likelihood thing where
you're predicting the center word
conditional on everything else fixed but
uh yeah it's roughly the same
um so here's the fun thing you can do
you can your query word can be a non
word you know so this can pass or we can
give it the Jabberwocky test where we
give a madeup word and we can see what
it thinks uh is similar now the words on
the nearest neighbors are things from
our uh uh from our uh vocabulary so it's
not going to make things up there uh but
you can see uh that uh uh we we find
some sort of reasonable things and
obviously this has a kind of
compositional structure um and my
student now my colleague at Deep M Wang
Lang who did this work claimed that this
is a reasonable approximation for a PhD
um that he was involved in all of those
activities academics study yeah yeah so
uh he I think that was why he was
particularly taken with it so uh but
yeah I mean it's these aren't perfect
models but it's also not uh um it's it's
not completely unreasonable what's
what's popping out
there um so we did another test uh just
very briefly um this I thought was
surprisingly cool my colleague Brian
rled at the Tepper business school had
uh is really interested in like how
color is used in advertising and he had
this data set of of uh two million word
name colors uh and and RGB values that
there's a website where people can like
upload their favorite colors and create
them uh and they do this for hours and
you can comment on each other's colors
and favorite your colors and sort of
like Facebook if you like colors um and
so it's got you know the standard colors
but then you've also got these really
sort of strange things over here uh and
so we were like well let's train a
character level model uh to see if we
can uh predict a color based on a color
name uh and so you know this looks just
like this except instead of building a
word embedding uh we're producing a a
color uh uh patch up at the top um and
then to train this thing we of course
have to back propagate from dark red to
that lighter red and measure an error so
how do we do that so this actually
actually gets to my point about
psychophysics that I when I asked Don
just a second ago so
um back in the like old days uh
psychologists spent a lot of time with
you know worrying about things like uh
minimum perceptible differences and
color is a great problem to work on
because they're just not very many
dimensions you need to perfectly
represent it so we actually have very
very good models of uh what people can
perceive uh in uh in color space and uh
there's something called the sea love uh
or lab uh color space where basically a
unit distance is supposed to be
perceptually uniform um so we were like
oh well that's exactly what we want so
we trained uh we represented colors uh
in that space and found that to be uh
useful and then we can do cool things
like you know predict the color of what
bacon lipstick uh would be um and uh we
can also go the other direction given a
color generate words um and we can
actually see some things uh one of the
other things we did to evaluate this uh
was uh give people what we called a
color Turing test where we said well the
model predicts a particular color and of
course these were held out colors not
present in the training Set uh and then
we said um does the true color that
actually was present in this data set we
actually had three different color data
sets uh which one do you think is a more
uh a better description and uh people
actually like our models um so I don't
think this is uh the most exciting stuff
but uh it's uh it was a fun project um
okay so concluding this like first
section here
um I think we can say more uh more
morphology is something that's
underexploited and these lstms based on
the pattern of results we're seeing when
we uh look at different kinds of
languages uh the more morphology there
is the more of a win we get uh but at
the same time we don't really lose
anything for using lstms to uh model uh
to build representations of of words so
basically to represent that Matrix they
are great at memorizing um and this is a
really robust finding so we've um seen
lots of following work U doing this
basically architectures like this uh
from a whole bunch of different groups
and on a whole bunch of different tasks
um and these are robust findings there's
also been you don't have to have an lstm
you can use convet it works great okay
um so now what about what about
generating you know we're we don't
always want to just read language
sometimes we want to produce it um yeah
three minutes okay um right okay um all
right then I'm going to say um basically
we should models things as a sequence of
characters um and um when we do that we
actually really don't lose very much so
lower is better here so we've gone you
know we've lost a little bit of uh you
know average uh entropy here um and if
we add something like latent discovery
of uh wordlike units this is the best uh
published uh number uh based on
characters we get uh we get things
better and this is pentry Bank modeling
um so can we do better um and I'm going
to say yes we can and I'm going to skip
ahead because I have three minutes or
two minutes now
um okay first we need one other
observation so not only do words occur
new words con constantly get generated
but words tend to be repeated rare words
tend to get be repeated more often than
they should so when you make up a new
word in an article say you don't just
say it once you tend to say it a lot um
and so there's this guy Ken Church who's
been saying this uh for 20 years and I
think this is a great title because
nobody remembers who Nora is um unless
you know that's how that really dates
this paper uh even if you don't like
don't look at the year um so he just
pointed out that when you see word Nora
once you're much more likely to see it
again a second time in fact almost
certainly um okay so basically the idea
is we're going to use a caching model
we're going to have a mechanism we're
not just going to generate words as a
sequence of characters we're also
periodically going to say you know what
I'm going to go back and copy something
that I just uh generated and this is
also not an a a new idea it's been
around a long time last year we saw a
couple neural variants of this but
nobody was dealing with open
vocabularies so people were just
assuming you would sample a word from a
fixed vocabulary including un and then
sometimes you would copy uh that word
but the whole point is we want to have
interesting things to copy and we wanted
to see if we could build good
representations for these newly created
words that would be amenable to letting
them be copied um this is also not
completely new it's not been done with
deep learning hierarchical pit manure
process language models uh instantiated
this idea in fact I think pitman's right
here at Berkeley um
so uh basically what we've got let me
just go through this model really
quickly um so we've got two parts of
this model one it's just a character
level language model we've got a word
level lstm that's tracking vectors and
at each time step we're going to feed in
a representation of the previous word
but it's going to be computed using a
sequence of of characters like we did uh
in the model we just talked about but
then rather than sampling a single word
at the time we're going to sample a
sequence of characters from a lstm
language model uh over characters
starting with this or transformation of
this as its initial state so this is a
little bit like a character language
Model A Word level language model that
uh spits things out that parameterizes
this distribution using an lstm and
we're going to add to it a cache and so
every time we generate a word WT we're
going to put it in the cache and an
empty slot s or in the least recently
used slot uh and we're going to set the
key associated with that word to be
whatever the hidden state of that lstm
is at that time if it's already there
we're going to just take an average of
the current key um and then basically
what we've got to do is decide what's
the probability of copying something
from the cache and what we're going to
do is we will attend over all of the
contents of the uh of the cache I'm not
going to go through the details here uh
and then we have to have a final
decision which is how are we going to
actually produce the next word are we
going to copy something from the cache
or are we going to generate it and so
we're going to also condition that on
the current state uh of the
lstm and so we can Define think of this
either as a joint probability or if we
assume the right independencies we can
marginalize
not an hmn um it is not it has no uh
there's no it's determined Min istic uh
the transitions given the given the
input uh are deterministic from one time
step to the next so we're going to
you that is conditional on the uh
currents yeah uh you could think about
this there's a sense in which it's an
hmm I mean it might be just complicated
to describe as an hmm But it is an HM uh
yes it's but the transition Dynamics are
completely determined by the emission so
they're coupled in a way where we
usually have stochasticity in both
components both in the transition and in
the emission here they're coupled in a
particular way that actually simplifies
inference so you may have a more
complicated description of the right
yeah um this is actually simpler because
I don't have to do dynamic programming
to train this so that's uh that's one
one nice thing um okay so we can we can
by assuming the right kind of
Independence assumptions uh we can get a
mixture of probability so we marginalize
that that decision um
byen um okay so finally the uh the
pieces so what we're going to do uh
we're generating this sentence up here
the Pokemon company
International uh formerly Pokemon and
we're generating that word Pokemon so
we've got we can copy it so what we're
going to do is we're going to take this
uh thing we're first going to decide
what's the probability of copying
something or generating something and
then we're going to decide what's the
probability of copying everything I've
seen in my cache and what's the
probability of generating ating the word
Pokémon uh from scratch and then we're
going to uh we'll add these two uh these
two things together um and that's going
to be the probability of our word
Pokemon um basically this stuff works uh
it even works on closed vocabulary
language models where there is nothing
really for the uh character model to do
um but on open vocabulary uh tasks uh we
do see some uh some fairly significant
uh results we've got a new oh yeah in
not to copy is cach limited because yes
you you do have a hyperparameter what do
you put in the cache um you also have to
have a good representation uh you have
to have there's a key associated with
everything in the cache and you you're
learning the representation of the key
but it might just be easier to learn to
spell words at one at a time than to
learn to generate the than to represent
things as a good key so in some sense
what I think we want this model to do is
copy things that are sensible to be
copied CED but otherwise it knows just
how language goes uh and it figures out
okay now I'm in the kind of context
where it's good to copy something from
the
past you're still you're just minimizing
cross entropy yeah yeah well talk to me
in the talk to me in the break um so we
have a new data set on a bunch of
languages same story everywhere um
there's some kind of cool analysis so
since this is probabilistic we can get a
posterior over what was used to generate
each word in every position
um and so we can see things like uh this
interesting mix of very frequent things
like a period and the wordthe and then
names tend to get copied uh out of the
cache and uh the things that don't tend
to get copied sometimes they're also
kind of rare they tend to be a little
bit more basic words but words like
numbers which are very rare but they
don't T Numbers don't tend to get
repeated verbatim In Articles you tend
to say you know the economy you know
grew by 12.2% in China last month and
then you don't repeat that number you
say other numbers but not exactly that
one so this this kind of makes sense um
okay um there are other things checklist
models lat and variable models
representing the whole intention of what
you want to say that can do this um I'll
just go back to these sort of
statistical facts we started with and
conclude um we can model this we should
don't just or uh the long tale of the
linguistic distribution there's
interesting stuff out there we can do
this okay that's
everything a quick question then we go
to break yeah yes so I I have a question
that's also relevant to the previous
talk on adversarial instances and I was
wondering for the character baseding
have you tried these instances of
spellings that are non-adversarial for
humans where you change each words you
sort of keep the first and the last
character of each word and you sort of
jumble the intervening words and fluent
readers have practically no difficulty
reading that at at the same Pace but I'm
wondering right that that's one of my
favorite examples of something that this
model doesn't do at all you can train it
to do that to be insensitive to that
what is the goal of deep model I mean is
it is it a tent to just get somethingone
that works or is the goal to try to get
something that human that's like humans
because if it's not the case that these
things are adversarial in the way then
basically it's just engineering yeah um
it's
uh it's a uh the both are goals so we we
want we want I mean I solve this I
wanted to model this as a I mean these
are the model modeling a a marginal
distribution of uh sentences is not a
cognitive problem it's a um it's a there
aren't very many cognitions of uh or
theories of cognition that would say
that in there it's an engineering task
uh there are things though uh we can ask
where these perceptual Illusions come
from like scrambling the internal things
uh of words certainly people don't ever
get that training data you're not
trained to do that you that's something
about the way the uh generalizations
that our uh you know V1 or whatever
makes when it learns to read uh that
just give us some insight into the kinds
of generalizations that it makes how
reading works um and we could think
about building models that try and look
more like that and why we would try then
we would test them to see if they were
generalizing in the same way this was
meant to solve a a just an engineering
task not to replicate that sort of
pattern but if you started thinking
about adversarial reading you would want
you would be concerned with that
psychophysical fact and you could either
TR try and solve that by changing the
training data to have a psycho physical
penalty in some sense or you could
change the architecture so its
regularization or generalization
Behavior matched a little bit more like
the human uh the human visual systems so
a much bigger question maybe we should
have coffee and uh uh and you can ask me
questions then thanks very
much